with me are two of the families who've
been involved in this very lengthy
campaign
john taggart whose father daniel was
shot 14 times
briege voyle whose mother joan connolly
was the mother of viet the only female
victim of bally murphy
we've talked many times brish you've
told me about your longing to have your
mother's name cleared
what did it mean to have a coroner say
that today it was just
amazing because she just she just said
exactly what we knew but now the world
knows
they all know that my mommy was an
innocent woman she wasn't a gun woman
she was an innocent woman who came out
of a place of safety to help a child
and i just cannot believe it but
there's also a sad bit to it because the
soldiers
the soldiers didn't cooperate with us so
at the courts so that meant we're still
left for a lot of questions
british what do you say to people who
would point out that it was a very
difficult time in northern ireland at
that stage and young soldiers
particularly from britain
found themselves in the middle of
turmoil do you have any sympathy
for them well to be honest with you they
were paratroopers you should never been
in belfast
they're a combat group they they were
for
places where there was big wars
they were sent to belfast on a defer to
help make peace
but they didn't the paratroopers come in
and they wrecked havoc around our areas
killing our men women and children
are leaving the maine that should never
been allowed to happen
i am delighted my mom is innocent which
i've always said she was innocent
and the people in ireland know she's
innocent i have traveled the world
to say that my mum was innocent but now
a court of law has said
that my mummy was an innocent woman and
that cannot be taken away from it
john tiger you've been at the forefront
of this campaign for
49 years or the best part of it
your family must be hugely relieved to
hear today
that your father has been declared an
innocent man yeah that
that's what we campaigned for all these
years the determination the dignity of
the
families over the years is is tremendous
i when we started this campaign it was
determination
and the anger of what happened to our
loved ones my daddy was murdered
50 years ago he was shot 14 times
the day after all the hard campaign and
after all the hard work
he's declared innocent she repeated at
the end that all the victims
are were innocent and the arizona jew
force that was used
and all them they're all shot by the
army the coroner
talked today about her hope that you
would maybe be able to
move on now find some peace find some
healing
will it be possible for you to do that
now it will
no we we can we can rest my father can
rest in peace
that he's an innocent man that's that
means a lot to me
uh up until now my grandkids would have
been seen
in history that he was a con man the
official verdict
is innocent my father is innocent
of what the lies it was told by generals
like
captain mick jackson entertained that
all our loved ones work on men and gun
women
that there's been cleared that's been
dumped and threw in the bin
and elizabeth was told have him
overturned today
that's what our campaign was about this
week in rails my father can rest a piece
and i i will rest easy now reese let me
ask you just one last question
this coincides of course today with
mention in the queen's speech of the
possibility of legislation that would
end
historical prosecutions how do you feel
about that happening on the same day
that your loved ones are declared
innocent i i just
can't really understand i think it's
from the british government's very
disrespectful because realistically
they're talking about veterans who've
had a life they came here and they
killed our loved ones and they went home
and carried on having a life we have had
to live 50 years without our loved ones
my mommy
she's got 24 grandchildren and
20 great grandchildren and she would
have just had a really good life and why
should
they have taken it away from her we have
got justice to
today to say that she was an innocent
woman but they never
nobody can nobody the army will come
forward and tell us
why why she was shot
why has anybody got a right to come and
murder our loved ones
and think that they can just walk away
murder is murder
everybody's entitled tell justice
everybody's entitled to a proper
investigation
for 50 years we never got it and we were
told that we wouldn't get one now that's
why we went down this route
of an inquest brees thank you very much
john
thank you for talking to us i know this
has been a very long journey for you
both